to that roll call of names in america's
epidemic of gun violence we can now add
the oxford high school a mass shooting
at lunchtime and three teenagers dead
within five minutes of the first
emergency calls a 15 year old student at
the school was in custody but not before
11 people had been shot and families had
endured the panic and confusion
i'm just so emotional because
you never think it's gonna happen here
and
the kids just are all a big part of this
community and it is i'm so scared for
them and my daughter is safe but i don't
know if all of her friends are safe and
i don't know if my nieces and nephews
are safe
at the suspected gunman's family home
police searched into the night they say
the pistol used was bought by his father
four days ago as yet they don't know any
motive pictures posted on social media
purport to show the student posing with
the gun
shooting with it and had posted pictures
of a target and the weapon
that's all part of what's being looked
at
we're going to do a deep dive
on the social media and all the
activities of this young man
so many communities in america have been
through this michigan's governor
expressing what many feel
this is a uniquely american problem that
we need to address but at this juncture
i think we need to focus on the
community the families supporting all
the first responders including
incredible people at our hospitals that
are working so hard to save the lives of
of those who are are fighting for their
lives right and i can tell you're so
deep as you should be if you're a mom
and you're a human being you're so
deeply affected by this talk to us about
that
okay this is every parent's worst
nightmare
and once again an american president
forced to offer consolation
my heart goes out to the families
enduring the unimaginable grief of
losing a loved one that whole community
has to be
just in a state of shock right now
police say they're trolling social media
and footage from dozens of security
cameras those who count these things say
this is the 53rd school shooting in
america this year tragically it is
almost certainly not the last greg milam
sky news